kannst du die tomate mit mutes immer
älter dieser gerät definitiv nicht so
halten und durch beispiel genau also wo
ich nehme mit schneidiger inhaftierte
hannover doch keiner sprach von wenig
los ist das bild gemacht siehe extra es
gibt keine schlechte kind es gibt keine
böse kind die kinder wersau gemacht von
uns erwachsene von uns erwachsenen
die caribo witsch arbeitet mit
schwierigen jugendlichen
sie übernimmt wenn schulpsychologie und
sonderpädagogik nicht mehr weiter wissen
die nach erzieherin kritisiert
auffällige kinder würden viel zu schnell
in therapien gesteckt und mit
medikamenten zitiert
doch meist seien sie gar nicht krank
sondern schlecht erzogen ist es wirklich
so einfach und wie arbeitet akribisch
mit kindern bei denen alle maßnahmen
versagt haben
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
ganz gut
simon triebes bundschuh weise heim
karriere polizeieinsätze
er ist gut die nach erzieherin
überschüttete ihre klienten mit
zuneigung und präsenz die jugendlichen
abgestumpft von jahrelangen erfolglosen
therapien sollen spüren jetzt weht ein
anderer wind
simons mutter 14 jahre alt als sie mit
ihm schwanger wurde
er wuchs bei den großeltern und in
heimen auf mami hatte ich nicht
abgeschoben
das war nicht jede idee man hat gemeint
sie sei unfähig es wird schwierig das
habe ich ihnen gesagt nach 13 jahren
eigene kind zu sich haben und für simon
ist noch schwieriger und noch
schwieriger
seit simon auch noch aus dem letzten
heimflug lebt der 13 jährige erstmals
bei seiner mutter
das hatte sie sich immer gewünscht dass
ich schon nach kurzer zeit
professionelle hilfe braucht konnte sie
nicht aber erzählt mir jetzt wie ist
dass wir haben uns paar tage nicht
gesehen
es ist aber besser kommunizieren ist
höflich liebe leicht was zeigt dass es
war einfach so und so ist es und so ist
der zweig optimismus der mutter geht ins
leere
simon hat in seinem bisherigen leben
stets gehört sie sei unfähig sich um ihn
zu kümmern
nun dritte den beweis dazu gnadenlos an
simon ich hoffe es das bin ich die
letzte
ich wünsche mir dass und du was wären so
die enkel das wäre ja das ist leider
klappt alles gut geht dass miss
schönheit mit den namen dieser schritt
so herzlicher dank ich bin ich bin
positiv überrascht sehr sehr glücklich
[Musik]
um der mutter mut zu machen verströmt
die nach erzieherin optimismus doch
simon ist einer der schwierigsten fälle
in ihrer 20-jährigen karriere
meist übernimmt sie ihre klienten von
der kest von schulbehörden und
jugendanwaltschaften sie ist oft die
letzte chance für die jugendlichen und
die letzte hoffnung für die eltern die
am samstag dass die ohne ohne polizei
eine woche verbringt in polizeiliche
einsatz sie das spiel viel wichtig ist
dass es mir heute auf gefahren nicht
heute aber letzte woche auch dass er
solche kinder brauchen respektperson
jemand hätten vertrauen wie katarina
witt will diese vertraute sein
sie versteht sich als anwältin der
jugendlichen ist sieben tage die woche
rund um die uhr für sie erreichbar
sie besucht ihre klienten stets zu hause
um einen einblick in die familie zu
bekommen
den meist sei das elternhaus der
nährboden für die probleme der kinder
karibik legt großen wert auf ein
gepflegtes äußeres auf anstand und
manieren
sie will den jugendlichen vorbild sein
und ihnen traditionelle werte und normen
vermitteln
er begrüßt durchmachen und blutet das
auto mit aktien bezahlen
kaputt gemacht ja denn hat das gemacht
du deine mutter in einem wutanfall hat
er alles kurz und klein geschlagen
leandro wurde bereits im kindergarten
erstmals psychologisch abgeklärt weil er
den unterricht störte die diagnose
aufmerksamkeitsdefizit hyperaktivitäts
er hat mir davon geschlagen
dem habe ich ihn gefragt da wird die
täter blau nasenbluten gehabt habe
jedenfalls die nase gebrochen und zwar
hass und versuchen somit macht wir
schaffen das sagt ihr gesagt
der 13 jährige flog aus schulen und
heimen vor zwei monaten übernommen sowie
karibik
sie stoppte alle therapien setzte das
ritalin ab von dem leandro die
höchstdosis nahm er sei nicht krank
sondern schlecht erzogen
langsam aber sicher geht um sie und ihre
mal dass sie und ihre entscheidungen
treffen teilnahm und papa sind chef hier
zu hause nicht umgekehrt was du weisst
was hast du vorne gemacht die mich
einfach korridors russische
kaputtgemacht weg alles was die leute
habe gekauft lieber mensch und es geht
mir nur dass nicht viel zu bestrafen
sondern dass du lebst
die hütte zu ordnen dass der vater sagt
und deine mutter dass ich ja und da mein
punkt fertig los die nach erzieherin
sagt oft herrsche in familien keine
hierarchie eltern suchten das problem
beim kind um sich nicht mit ihren
eigenen rolle beschäftigen zu müssen
weißt du dass du kannst nicht mehr wer
nicht lernt rosa opfer einer verfehlten
schulpsychologie und sonderpädagogik
sagt karibik gern überzeugt dass svp
mitglied ist
in ihrem buch übt sie massive kritik das
etablierte system suche fehler statt
lösungen und mit den schwächen der
kinder geld zu verdienen wenn sie
eigentlich hunderte von studiert der
spezialistinnen und spezialisten
vorwerfen eigentlich novelle gauck
machen
mit deiner kinder wissen sie dass keine
vorwurf ein gesunder mensch ein gesundes
kind muss man nicht therapieren man
kategorisieren unsere kindheit
man sucht ihn ein kern gesunde kind
diagnose man macht kinder kaputt anstatt
kinder zu akzeptieren so wie sie sind
katarina witt hat eine schlaflose nacht
hinter sich
simon war auf kurve gilt seinen nach
erzieherinnen und die polizei auf trab
er kann nicht anders dass es in seinem
muskel hat 13 jahre so gelebt beziehung
zur mutter hatte keine zu erwachsene
auch er ist beziehungsunfähig
gesellschaftlich gesehen hat keine
freiheit gelege nicht ein baum ohne
wurzeln
er sucht diese wurzeln über aber findet
nicht so simon
nimmst du diese ja wenn man begrüßt wird
nimmt dass das wächst immer sie ist
nicht anstellen denn holz to be ok ich
bin müde
warum sich also gut dann gehen wir auch
davon betroffen
keine mutter meinte zimmer und dir du
was man mit dem die polizei ganz witzig
zu reden aber sie kann nicht dafür
sie möchte diese beziehung auch so auch
sehr viel gefühl er gut aber sie möchte
diese beziehung aufbauen
trotz einer neuen wohnung
simon weigert sich bei seiner mutter zu
leben simon deine mutter wirklich stimmt
es nicht dass java simons die zeit die
das also dass ich irgendwie im blut
gehört bevor das klang
bestellen sie jetzt die aktuelle habe
und dass nun politiker und ähnliche
nortel
bislang wurde dafür in lotte rechtsakte
ist genauso genauso um jeden wochen
wehrt sich
lauf gehabt ja ok will das probierte
simon absicht aber okay vergangenheit
ich sehr belastet viel viel arbeiten
dass ich so simon
das ist nicht immer einfach immer
schwierig besonders nun kommt ruhig
sport wie ich schlafe jedoch okay wenn
du mal schmeißt ruft er holt das ist
eine ausnahme hat sein name der
auffassung simon versand ständig man
kann susanne reden aber nicht nicht
reiten finden
vor drei monate studierst du mit deiner
mama soja war so ähnlich dann dann hat
sich die tomaten zu total war spitze die
bis dahin bringen
simone zeit entsprechen diese sie zugab
das ist so wie simon letztes mal und das
wäre schade
das sagte jan o aber hören
aber nicht kopfüber diesen warum ja aber
was immer die die cash die wissen genau
und alle behörde wissen dass du nirgends
ruhe hast dass du aus dem spiel wenn es
dort nicht lange bestand ja immer am
besten wäre mit marie simon pierre
ich bitte sie kombiniert
die hälse wie katarina witt das aus ihre
biografie macht klar die 57-jährige ist
eine kämpferin
1990 kam sie mit ihrer tochter aus dem
heutigen montenegro in die schweiz eine
iec und erst noch alleinerziehend sie
bildete sich zur therapeutin und
konfliktmanagerin weiter dutzende von
typen wie sie sie nennt haben seit er
dankt ihr die kurve gekriegt
oft wenn ich bin überfordert mit meinen
jungs komme ich nicht weiter ziehe ich
mich zurück dass ich mich überlege wie
und weite frau darüber wie es gibt nur
mit ihrer typen gibt es nicht andere
sondern warum habe ich nicht mehr
geheiratet
ich habe mich entschieden für mein büro
für meine berufung
und ein solcher berufung das gefälle
nicht gegangen
simon verschlingt ihre ganze energie
er weigert sich standhaft bei seiner
mutter zu leben an bord was von ihnen
hier und ich mache es so genannte bis
hier wollten die graben ist so groß er
suchte zuwendung zuneigung er sucht
anschluss findet leider auf falsche weg
geben sie also zeigen sie im anstalt
kommt das nicht das heißt sagte sie
simon kuch zu mama hier trotzdem wie er
ist aber zeit ist immer auch ihre liebe
die auch nicht immer so redet man nicht
jetzt ist fertig jetzt werde mit einem
oder es kommt studiums orte wo alle
leute hast du also ganze umgebung
raschere land lebt sie nun in
wackersdorf darf der achter schnorre tut
in christus selber simon s corp
das größeren ich mache nicht lange und
hat sich verloren
das kommt gut an
[Musik]
später erfährt in auch erzieherin dass
simons mutter den kampf aufgegeben hat
simon lebt wieder im heim
er hat den streit gewonnen in dem es nur
verlierer gibt
[Musik]
die diese graben zwischen in seiner
mutter war zu groß dass sie war für ihn
total fremd vielleicht gar keine chance
gelassen
nein nein habe ganz gute beziehung zu
ihm aufgebaut wollte er hat sie
akzeptiert dass biologische mutter mit
ihr zusammenzuleben wollte er nicht
das hat er immer wieder kommuniziert
weiter dass mussawi karrubi akzeptieren
ihre methode funktioniert nur wenn die
eltern bereit sind den schwierigen weg
mitzugehen weil anders sieht es gut aus
die nach erzieherin hat zwei monate lang
mit ihm gearbeitet
er besuchte jetzt die öffentliche
dorfschule ein großer erfolg für einen
der noch vor kurzem in einer aufwändigen
eins-zu-eins-betreuung steckte riberys
überzeugte die lehrerin ihm eine chance
zu geben
einfach kunst ich will noch besser zu
präsidieren
genau das eben genau das versuche ich
bitte dich wie wir müssen alles
ausprobieren
dass ich einfach mein leben mit dir
reden sie
es heißt nonverbal ich respektiere dich
ich höre zu ich nehme mit sein wenn du
wenn du sie ruhig anschaust und alles
einfach aufnehmen das sei okay
aha erhöht hat mich wir gingen mit
kinder heute
ich habe viel gelacht und mangel dass
man sein herz zu bekannten lustige einen
lustigen er wird auch probleme
und du hast gesagt warum hast du geboren
bist baron beim konzert werde
das hat niemand gesagt es gibt doch
nicht dass eine gute konzepte dass du
nur gehör
man hat die gesagt tara und du denkst du
immer probleme und natur index habe
probleme mit dem mittel der letzten nach
acht monaten arbeit mit sophie katharina
witt hatte andere später sogar den
übertritt in die oberstufe geschafft
wenn von 100 kindern möglich ist
wenn sich zu retten es geht nicht sehr
kraft
[Musik]